tournaments
first one oh that's i got this from you
right recently this is from jay
okay you have to say that every time we
do a current event i don't know who's
gonna
just say that
i'm not gonna say it then but if it's
bad i'll say it's brendan's
you can do that you got it it's from jay
o you football player spencer jones
starts a fight with a smaller kid in a
bar and gets his ass
absolutely whooped turns out the kid has
done a ton of mma training
i haven't seen the videos there they got
a video of it let me know
he's an ou football player oh look at
that little dude
[ __ ] you take oh [ __ ]
ooh body lock ew this pee all over the
[ __ ] floor
first of all that's the least of the
concerns your power oh jeffy gets back
and
chokes him out that's what you call
getting a piss beat out yeah
guys are still pissed he's a little dude
too
oh the guillotine
damn he has he has cowboy boots on
but this dude is [ __ ] this oh you
football player oh yo
oh damn that guy's getting really bad oh
wow bro
wait no no it was one or more both of
them were getting [ __ ] up
no no no because that's that dude's with
the oh he's not here with the football
player
yeah the dude the dude
i have cowboy boots
jones picked a fight against a guy with
a decade a decade
a 10 years of mma training at ou bar
this past weekend it didn't end well for
him you almost lost his eye
he's currently come from eye surgery
damn
spring football that was [ __ ]
gangster so wait it says oh boy well
would you look
this girl scroll please chin would you
look at that the kid even looked at his
body like man do we really have to do
this right now
yeah yeah yeah but if they really want
to do this bro i knew it was real cause
when a dude when he pushed him he did
the nose
yeah he did that it was just a real joke
and punches bruce lee
he was like okay damn he should have
known when he did that little
bro he started hitting him with the
combos bro he didn't he didn't wait for
him no that's what you get
though man trying to be a bully on the
small yeah yeah let me see that again
and that and he's bigger than that kid
oh way bigger
he laughed and he like broke you know we
just rushed him
he had his friend the whole time bro he
goes we going to do this
and then it's homie got on the other
dude he went like this
that was
[Applause]
oh
how bad is this football play again just
getting roasted online now
bro look at this dude in a bubble jacket
you have to have
eye surgery dude like wait whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa man just trying to take a
pic
he should he should have gave him a
swirly yeah oh yeah i was
stuffed his head in the toilet dude he's
in cowboy boots
yes you remember friday afternoons with
cat williams like hold on play work with
a monster and then watch homie gets
slammed
tap out i love the guy calling out the
moves i wonder why he let go the choke
what do i just shouldn't choke him to
sleep i'm not oh i am dude they beat
them they beat the [ __ ] out of these
boys
they [ __ ] get spout oh dude that
football player didn't get one punch in
no you just defended himself though he
got slapped in that fight
yeah nothing worse than you you could
tell his homie didn't want anything
because he looking in the mirror like
[ __ ]
was holding his position he played no he
didn't
recovering from eye surgery he looks
like a bully there
that mustache yeah yeah he got his
ass beat cost him his left eye nearly
cost him left eye
you won't know what he's a wide receiver
he's a wide receiver
oh he's a wide receiver yeah uh he's on
um he red shirt a white wide receiver
would you like a tough go
well that's why he's fighting running
for his respect and he's already is he a
registered
player at all yeah he definitely played
yeah he's big damn
hold up
he just kept him his boys just got beat
up see he looks different right there
he's from nashville
academic all big 12 first team honoree
winner of the
hold oh he's the ho holder of the year
what is it
all 11 games so he's a holder for the
kicker that's when he's got it while he
holds it for the kicker
important job he played in all the games
and got beat up damn and he's a senior
this year
you know you say he's a senior a red
shirt singer yeah
yeah well richard senior [ __ ] man what
does that mean registered
five year player so you get four years
of eligibility redshirt gives you a
fifth year
oh god i got i got it well i think the
way you want to start your monday
no sure bro you got [ __ ]
oklahoma holder spencer joint jones
seriously injured in bar fight
god dude that's what i'm saying you
don't know me when did he lose his eye
though because i'm seeing a boy in the
whole time
because probably when he mounted him he
was like oh yeah
man [ __ ] should be learning
[ __ ] bro you don't know who you messing
with hold on it says uh in jones version
of events as he told the daily by glass
he was trying to act as a peacekeeper
which doesn't have to match up with the
brief snip of the pre-fight conversation
you see in the video
he was trying to de-escalate the
situation but unfortunate wasn't
de-escalade despite his best efforts
he became a victim of the vicious
assault you've seen i don't think he's a
victim whatever the intent is putting
your finger in someone's face while you
and your friend say look at me [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here
yeah it's not really the way so he's
playing victim
on this he's trying to but the video
says otherwise yeah
he's asking de-escalated yeah he was all
over dude he had one eye he's like
listen man
when he gets back to that locker room oh
[ __ ] let that little boy in cowboy boots
beat you up like you got one eye now
how you gonna hold the ball for the
kicker damn well he got that choking
i know i know but oh boy i love how boy
just kept looking at his homie the whole
time like man bro what you thinking did
he slap
[ __ ] i'm thinking what you thinking no
that's not that's slap that's not
so disrespectful i don't listen i don't
know why you're uh
let's see the doctor brooks came up
search saying he's extraordinarily lucky
at this point he's like he didn't lose
the eye altogether
wow that's what the goddess oh so he
[ __ ] that he broke his eye
uh orbiting orbital rebuilding the
orbital socket things everything's
eventually come back to normal
it's going to take a while for him to
recover that's for and for what dude
because you want to be an [ __ ] in a
bathroom also
he's a lot of people he has that liquid
courage though a lot of people doing mma
man you know a lot of people
[ __ ] a lot of people dude kenny floyd
looks like a straight up nerd
pick a fight with kenny let me know how
it goes first who's that kenny flooring
i don't think i know he's a mma fighter
but he's like
he looks like a nerdy dude he will rock
your [ __ ] world
damn there's a lot of nerdy guys that
are badasses man
like you would pick a fight in a bar
with that guy no
[ __ ] no he's tiny you would i'm not
picking a [ __ ] no
we're not people oh not you personally
clearly i'm saying like if you're
picking on me
i was like don't set me up
he just looks like your average joe yeah
yeah he kind of looks like sasha baron
cohen
and he also kind of looks like a homie
that was in den of thieves
no that's our brother the other guy the
dude that's the villain
bro he looked like the dea in snowfall
no
i don't know any of these references but
uh yeah she shall not
be all right
i was like what yeah chase is
that's a kid yeah [ __ ] your world
19 i think young um
there's a few guys you don't want to
mess with first of all
nerd first of all as soon as i see the
cauliflower here i'm back in the [ __ ]
that's it all right you already know
yeah right there that's the tail some
don't have it though
oh really not everybody don't have it
not everyone gets it you gotta be a vet
uh or just some people are more prone to
it i don't know if chase has any does he
do all the wrestlers do you can't tell
yeah you just
exactly that's the thing you can't
[ __ ] tell because everybody's going
to learn something and he got his curls
hiding his ears
yeah he's a little bit everybody out
there learning something i know
yeah i said who street fights this day
and age
hey i prefer that that's a shootout at
least someone i know
in the bathroom in a bathroom pissed all
over the floor this was all about
that's what i would have thought about
yeah
with toilet paper on the floor hell no
speaking of piss can we take a break i
got a pig
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song